a finales de los años 50 william
phillips observó la correlación que
había entre el desempleo e inflación
aquí también tengo una foto de renfe ser
porque él notó esta relación algunas
décadas antes pero esa relación tomó el
nombre de felap porque su publicación
captura el interés de las personas y la
relación de la que yo hablo no es tan
sorprendente parece que sale un poco de
lo que es el sentido común pero veremos
algunos ejemplos que parecen ir en
contra de esta relación
si yo gráfica el porcentaje de desempleo
aquí en el eje el porcentaje de
desempleo en mi eje horizontal y gráfico
lo que es la inflación en el otro eje en
el eje vertical pongo aquí la inflación
en el otro eje
a inflación la inflación entonces bueno
yo aquí voy a elegir puntos al azar
él se dio cuenta de algo se dio cuenta
que en un año cuando había inflación
alta había bajo desempleo y el otro año
cuando había alto desempleo había baja
inflación como vemos no está tan claro
cuál está causando a cuál quizás ambas
están van del uno al otro en círculos
bueno quién sabe qué pase quizás en
otros años tienes una inflación mediana
o un porcentaje de desempleo
relativamente bajo y ves que a través de
los años se gráfica de esta manera bueno
lo pongo en otro color en el mismo así
que crear gráficas de información con
respecto a muchos años tienes inflación
ligeramente mayor o un menor desempleo
que quizás otros años y bueno puede
seguir así graficando datos también
puede ser el caso que tengas deflación y
lo que él notó fue una correlación que
hay una relación inversa aquí si
quisiéramos a cómo darle una curva a
estos puntos y sigo poniendo aquí puntos
al azar lo que haces es bueno quedaría
más o menos así la curva se ve algo de
esta manera y lo que está diciendo
generalmente es que cuando tú tienes
alta inflación qué es esto de aquí
arriba
aquí se representa aquí arriba tienes
alta inflación entonces tienes bajo
desempleo alta inflación y bajo
desempleo donde el bajo desempleo
claramente es algo bueno y acá abajo
tenemos baja inflación y alto porcentaje
de desempleo también hay que tomar en
cuenta que si está que si esta curva
llegara a cruzar el eje horizontal
entonces lo que pasaría es que
tendríamos deflación y aquí bueno aquí
pongo alto desempleo se me olvida
ponerlo completo tiene sentido todo esto
esto hace razonable sentido ya lo
habíamos hablado en sentido común antes
puedes imaginar aquí cuál está causando
a cuál cuál es el culpable de cuál pero
puedes pensar analizando un poco si
tienes bajo desempleo lo que es lo mismo
que alto empleo una manera de ver el
bajo desempleo es la siguiente tienes
altos beneficios del mercado de trabajo
y ahora con esta situación los
trabajadores tienen más poder lo escribo
aquí los trabajadores
tienen más poder más poder y si los
trabajadores tienen más poder entonces
los empleados tendrán que aumentar sus
salarios para que los retengan y si
tienen más poder entonces tienen más
opciones también lo pongo aquí tienen
más poder y tienen más opciones porque
muchos quieren dar empleo entonces
pensemos lo ahora desde este otro punto
de vista empleados empleados elevan
salarios ellos elevan salarios para
atraer y retener aunque claro cuando
cuando tú le tienes empleados y bueno
por decir cuando aumentan los salarios
aumentas el poder de compra el poder de
compra para los trabajadores entonces
aquí tenemos aumento de poder
adquisitivo aumento de poder adquisitivo
donde para trabajadores esto aumenta la
demanda para bienes y servicios y si
están incrementando su poder para bienes
y servicios van a incrementar la
utilización de todos los factores de
producción
run de capital espíritu empresarial de
labor entonces bueno esto te dará bajo
desempleo aún más y puedes imaginar si
ya tienes bajo porcentaje de desempleo
donde esté solamente un factor de
producción pero si piensas en todos los
factores de producción probablemente
sean todos altamente utilizados las
fábricas estarán en su máxima capacidad
el mercado de trabajo también están en
su máxima capacidad se incrementará la
compra de poder se incrementará la
demanda la demanda sube hay bajo
desempleo pero la capacidad de
utilización de trabajo está bajando hay
menos capacidad pero más demanda y esto
causará que los precios suban esto
causará que suban los precios que suban
los precios generalmente y si los
precios aumentan los trabajadores tienen
más poder y más opciones pero pero
también tienen más costos y lo pongo de
esta manera tienen tienen alto costo de
vida alto costo de vida
este es un diagrama nada más para que te
des una idea de lo que estamos viendo es
como para que vea la dinámica de lo que
se lleva
los trabajadores tienen mejor salario y
más opciones pero también un alto costo
de vida toda la economía se va cómo se
va inclinando entonces demandarán
mayores salarios aún con más razón y
esto seguirá así en ciclos aunque nada
parezca raro aquí si hay excepciones en
los 70s eeuu experimentó estanflación lo
cual es lo peor de todos los casos de
verdad causa temblar a los economistas
ya todo el mundo y lo que es alta
inflación y alto desempleo que está
justamente aquí y bueno las cosas que lo
pueden causar según en los setentas
aunque en economía no se sabe muy bien
cuál es la causa de las crisis pero una
de las causas que regularmente se cree
que es para causar estanflación es un
impacto en la oferta un impacto en la
oferta lo escribo aquí impacto en la
oferta el impacto fue causado por el
petróleo lo cual causó que todo fuera
más caro y también su producción todo se
fue hacia arriba y no dejó que el país
como un todo fuera o tuviera más
producción
una manera de pensarlo sería bueno los
precios aquí arriba causar un alto costo
de vida y bueno esta parte del ciclo que
normalmente asociamos con bajo desempleo
y alta inflación no ocurría así que esta
parte esto estoy aquí que estoy
encerrando no estaba ocurriendo y como
esos precios altos estaban esencialmente
saliendo del país
tú puedes imaginar como si empujara la
habilidad de las personas para pagar por
otras cosas entonces el alto costo de la
vida o los altos precios por petróleo y
voy a dibujar quien más líneas aunque
bueno tal vez complique más del diagrama
pero lo voy a dibujar puedes ver que
impide la demanda para la producción
doméstica entonces aquí yo pongo que
hubo retroalimentación negativa entonces
nadie quería comprar cosas en eeuu
porque todo estaba muy caro a causa del
petróleo y otros factores entonces
cuando la gente vio que había bajo
desempleo el gobierno quiso imprimir más
dinero para echar las cosas andar pero
ya no lograron que este ciclo virtual
que tenemos aquí ocurriera la economía
ya no pudo adaptarse adecuadamente para
que los empleados y recursos fueran
asignados eficientemente
pero todo esto de los 70 si viene al
caso porque quiero mostrarte esto no es
una ley no es claro no está claro que
está causando qué cosa pero si hubo una
situación los 70 es donde ocurrió
estanflación y lo opuesto esto es lo que
vimos a finales de los 90s donde
teníamos relativamente baja inflación y
teníamos relativamente bajo desempleo
esta es una buena situación que ocurrió
a finales de los 90s y el argumento que
hace mucha gente del por qué pudo
ocurrir esto de por qué este ciclo no
siguió y siguió porque los precios no
subieron es porque tenías esta otra
tendencia de enormes mejoras
tecnológicas había por ejemplo
computadoras telecomunicación internet
había está súper mega duper curva
proactiva y bueno si bien es cierto que
aunque había este ciclo había también un
incremento en el poder de compra y la
demanda subía la proactividad del país
estaba incrementando tanto que nos llevó
a inflación
simplemente se mantuvo en baja inflación
y bajo desempleo a finales de los
noventas y bueno en general es algo
elegante en qué pensar o al menos
parece tener sentido común pero como
todo en economía siempre es un poco más
complicado de lo que parece no es tan
solamente esta correlación lo que puedes
tú observar aquí puede ser generalmente
cierto pero siempre habrá casos que no
cumplan